Pinnochio is a software system for
automatic animation of 3d characters
given a 3d character mesh and a generic
skeletal motion Pinocchio adapts the
skeleton to the character and applies
the motion to the shape the results is
an animated character as we developed
Pinocchio we used about 70 different
characters for testing after Pinocchio
had been completed we tested it on 16
biped characters that would not see or
use during development here all 16 of
our test characters are shown a single
biped skeleton was used to animate all
of them demonstrating the generality of
our approach three of these characters
required a single manual hint to produce
a good motion on a mid-range PC
Pinocchio typically takes under a minute
to animate a character
Pinnochio can produce plausible
animations even in some unexpected cases
it can also work with non biped
skeletons we were unable to obtain a
cent or four motion capture this motion
is the capture of a human hopping
applied to a center skeleton
Pinocchio works as follows it packs
spheres into the character and
constructs a graph on their centers it
then finds an embedding of the given
skeleton into this graph that minimizes
a measure of distortion it uses
continuous optimization to refine the
positions of the skeleton joints within
the character it solves the diffusion
equilibrium equation on a character
surface to compute the bone weights for
skeleton subspace deformation once the
character is rigged
Pinocchio uses online motion retargeting
to eliminate foot skate
Pinocchio requires that the character be
given in roughly the same orientation
and pose as the skeleton this is the
results if the character's orientation
is slipped vertically Pinocchio has no
capability to differentiate between
materials this leads to unrealistic
rubbery motion of a knight's armor and a
woman's dress in our blind validation
test
Pinocchio correctly embedded the
skeleton into thirteen of our 16 test
models Pinocchio incorrectly embedded
the skeleton into these three test
characters however a manual hint for the
placement of one joint was sufficient to
correct the problem for each of them the
asymmetry in the middle character
skeleton is due to the asymmetry in the
character the following animations
demonstrated results on the more
interesting of our test characters
close-up
Pinnochio is best suited for children
and amateur animators it generates
pleasing animations automatically in
almost all of our tests with unfamiliar
3d shapes